For nearly a year now, fans of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe have been trying to puzzle
out where the story is going in the aftermath
of Avengers: Infinity War.
But now a new special look trailer has arrived
for Avengers: Endgame, the franchise's 22nd
movie, on the very same morning that tickets
for the movie went on sale.
Barely a minute long, the teaser provides
some of the most thrilling and substantial
Endgame footage we've seen yet.
Want to know how the trailer might clue us
in to what actually happens in the movie?
Here's a potentially spoiler-filled look at
all the small details you may have missed
in the special look trailer for Avengers:
Endgame.
Everyone knows Endgame is revving up for a
rematch between the Avengers and Thanos, a
grudge match which the new trailer seems to
explicitly show.
But what if that rematch happens sooner than
we think?
It's very likely.
A mix of rumors and reports indicate that
the marketing for Avengers: Endgame features
footage from only the first 15 or 20 minutes
of the movie, keeping the secrets of its story
held close to the vest until the movie has
rolled out in theaters.
While the "15-to-20 minute" window that's
been reported doesn't seem exactly right,
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has said in
an interview with MTV News that those reports
are still "somewhat accurate."
If he's being truthful, it implies that the
trailer footage of the Avengers facing off
against Thanos again won't come at the end
of the movie, but instead somewhere in the
first act.
This theory tracks with multiple purported
leaks from the movie that have claimed the
Avengers will team up to fight Thanos in space
somewhere in the beginning of Endgame.
It's possible that the team will even defeat
him in this battle… but in a way that prevents
the fallen from being revived.
If it feels wild to you, consider that Infinity
War kicked off with Hulk fighting Thanos within
the first five minutes of the film.
So if you think it's unlikely that this movie
will hit the ground running with its plot,
think again.
These are going to be 3 dense hours.
One of the biggest rumors that's been swirling
about Avengers: Endgame is that it will feature
a significant jump forward in time, with some
reports claiming the whole movie would be
set five years after Infinity War.
The trailers have finally given us enough
footage to assume that a time jump will indeed
occur, but in the middle of the movie, rather
than before it begins.
The biggest clue about when the Avengers are
at any given point is the hairstyle of Natasha,
aka Black Widow.
In Infinity War, she memorably sports a blonde
bob, presumably to work incognito as a member
of Cap's secret Avengers.
The trailers for Endgame have shown the character
with both that same blonde hairdo, but also
a return to her longer red-haired style, similar
to what she wore in previous movies.
In the new trailer, Natasha can be seen with
her Infinity War haircut in the Guardians'
Benatar ship, presumably on the way to fight
Thanos somewhere in space an act which seems
to be predicted by Bruce Banner's line:
"If we do this, we'd be going in short-handed."
That phrasing seems to imply that the Avengers
will take the fight to Thanos where he is…
wherever he is.
At the end of Infinity War, Thanos retired
to a peaceful life on a farm on a planet the
Russo brothers have called Titan II.
The special look trailer seems like it might
show the Avengers encountering him back on
the first Titan, in the still-smoldering rubble
left behind from their first encounter with
him.
Whatever happens in this fight, it seems like
it won't result in the revival of the people
Thanos snapped away.
After the Snap in Infinity War, Thanos' gauntlet
was left smoldering and damaged, potentially
leaving him vulnerable to attack especially
if the team now has Captain Marvel on their
side.
"I like this one."
If they actually do kill Thanos, then it makes
sense why the Avengers and the world would
begin to move on with their lives afterward
which is what seems to be happening in the
previously-released Super Bowl teaser, which
showed many shots of an abandoned and neglected
world.
But this status quo would be disrupted by
the return of Scott Lang's Ant-Man, who was
seen in the second trailer roaming around
a world well after the Snap.
If Ant-Man approaches the Avengers with his
new knowledge of time travel, it could lead
the team to reunite for a full victory not
just beating Thanos, but keeping him from
ever killing the trillions of people he did
in Infinity War.
Apart from all of the time travel, time skip,
rematch shenanigans, the new footage also
shows a remarkably touching moment between
two characters, the relevance of which may
have slipped by some viewers.
The first trailer for Endgame saw Tony and
Nebula adrift in space on the now-abandoned
Benatar, and the special look teaser seems
to show the moment the two will arrive back
on Earth, with Tony being embraced by Pepper
Potts and Nebula getting her bearings as she
lands on Earth for the first time.
While Rocket saw Groot fall away into dust
at the end of ​Avengers: Infinity War​,
he has no knowledge whatsoever regarding the
fate of the rest of his team.
For all he knows, when he sees the ​Benatar​
screaming into the Earth's atmosphere for
a landing, it's the rest of his team coming
back ready to pick him up and get out of there.
So imagine his surprise when he sees Nebula,
and only Nebula, instead.
This moment, of these two former enemies offering
each other some comfort, is more than likely
the moment Rocket realizes that he's lost
everyone to Thanos, and it's probably not
long before these two outer space outcasts
decide to suit up as Avengers instead.
Fans have known for quite a while that the
production of ​Avengers: Endgame​ involved
the recreation of setpieces from past movies
in the MCU specifically the Battle of New
York​ against Thanos' army of Chitauri that
wrapped up the end of the first ​Avengers​
movie.
Leaked set photos are the main culprit for
why so many fans figure Endgame will center
on time travel.
But the latest trailer seems to show some
footage of the Avengers actually working in
the past.
During the special look spot, there's a brief
moment​ that shows Iron Man soaring through
the sky in what appears to be New York City,
with the clip looking like it could have come
straight out of the first ​Avengers​.
If anything, it's certainly a much sunnier
look at the city than the rest of ​Endgame​'s
marketing​ has shown so far.
So is this a shot of future Tony soaring through
past New York, working on some plan to get
the Space Stone out of the Tesseract before
Loki can even begin the invasion?
It seems possible, and even likely, that this
shot is one of our first looks at the ​Endgame​'s
tour through Marvel movies' past.
With this final movie of Phase Three, the
relationship between Iron Man and Captain
America seems to finally be coming full circle.
Just check out this huge moment:
"You trust me?"
"I do."
And that looks like more than just a handshake:
it looks like it could be the moment that
signifies the official repair of their relationship.
This is something we've been waiting for since
the end of Captain America: Civil War, a handshake
three years in the making.
One question that remains is just which Tony
and Steve this is.
If this encounter takes place while the Avengers
are travelling through time, then it's possible
that this meetup is of present Tony and a
past version of Steve, or vice versa.
It's hard to tell, but it is interesting to
note that Steve is wearing what looks like
his outfit from ​Infinity War​, but without
the beard, potentially implying that this
is indeed a Cap post-​Infinity War​.
If that's the case, then this clip really
does show our heroes making good after all
these years, back on each others' side to
face Thanos' ultimate threat.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.